dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonaife
the research field of image translation
with the aid of learning algorithms has
been
on fire lately for instance this earlier
technique would look at a large number
of animal faces
and could interpolate between them or in
other words
blend one kind of dog into another breed
but that's not all because it could even
transform dogs into cats
or create these glorious plump cats and
cheetahs
the results were absolutely stunning
however
it would only work on the domains it was
trained on in other words
it could only translate to and from
species that it took the time to learn
about
this new method offers something really
amazing
it can handle multiple domains or
multiple breeds if you will
even ones that it hadn't seen previously
that sounds
flat out impossible so let's have a look
at some results
this dog will be used as content
therefore the output should have a
similar pose
but its breed has to be changed to this
one
but there is one little problem and that
problem is
that the ai has never seen this breed
before this will be very challenging
because we only see the head of the dog
used for style
should the body of the dog also get
curly hair you only know
if you know this particular dog breed or
if you're smart
and can infer missing information by
looking at other kinds of dogs
let's see the result incredible
the remnants of the leash also remain
there in the output results
it also did a nearly impeccable job with
this bird
where again the style image is from a
previously unseen breed
now this is of course a remarkably
difficult problem domain
translating into different kinds of
animals that you know nothing about
apart from a tiny cropped image this
would be quite a challenge
even for a human however this one is not
the first technique to attempt to solve
it
so let's see how it stacks up against
the previous method
this one is from just a year ago and you
will see in a moment
how much this field has progressed since
then for instance
in this output we get two dogs which
seems to be a mix
of the content and the style dog and
while the new method
still seems to have some structural
issues the dog type
and the pose is indeed correct the rest
of the results also appear to be
significantly better
but what do you think did you notice
something weird let me know in the
comments below
and now let's transition into image
interpolation
this will be a touch more involved than
previous interpolation efforts
you see in this previous paper we had a
source
and the target image and the ai was
asked to generate
intermediate images between them simple
enough
in this case however we have not two but
three images as an input
there will be a content image this will
provide the high level features such as
pose
and its style is going to transition
from this to this
the goal is that the content image
remains intact
while transforming one breed or species
into another
this particular example is one of my
favorites such
a beautiful transition and surely not
all
but many of the intermediate images
could stand on their own
again the style images are from unseen
species
not all cases do this well with the
intermediate images however
here we start with one eye because the
content
and the style image have one eye visible
while the target style of the owl
has two how do we solve that of course
with nuclear fission
look very amusing
loving this example especially how
impossible it seems
because the owl is looking into the
camera with both eyes
while we see its backside below the head
if it look to the side like the input
content image this might be a
possibility
but with this contorted body posture i
am not so sure
so i'll give it a pass on this one so
there you go
transforming one known animal into a
different one that the ai
has never seen before and it is already
doing a more than formidable job at that
what a time to be alive this episode has
been supported
by lambda gpu cloud if you're looking
for inexpensive
cloud gpus for ai check out lambda
gpu cloud they've recently launched
quadro rtx 6000
rtx 8000 and v100 instances
and hold on to your papers because
lambda gpu cloud can
cost less than half of aws and azure
plus they are the only cloud service
with 48 gigabyte
rdx 8000 join researchers at
organizations like apple
mit and caltech in using lambda cloud
instances
workstations or servers make sure to go
to lambdalabs.com
papers to sign up for one of their
amazing gpu instances today
our thanks to lambda for their
long-standing support and
for helping us make better videos for
you thanks for watching and for your
generous support and i'll see you
next time